make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin okay so we are picking back
up with injustice year
zero basically the prequel to the comic
injustice gods among us
and initially this was designed to
answer the question how different would
things have been
if the jsa had been around during
injustice now we don't really know how
this sandwiches
into injustice itself we'll have to wait
until we get to the end of this in order
to find
out but the long and short of this is
that in the first video that we did we
had a guy named andre shavard who was
part of a group called the boy commandos
we'll actually talk more about that in
this video but he was a guy who wanted
to be broken out of prison so he could
see his son one last time and basically
said whoever can do it will get absolute
power
the joker of course responded and now
we're finding out how that how the joker
is going to attain that absolute power
and so what we end up learning is that
in 1945
andre shafard was fighting alongside a
group called the boy commandos now this
was an actual line of comics in dc back
during the 1940s but
the idea behind this was that at some
point an amulet of chaos had been
discovered right and it seems to be the
antithesis
of the amulet of order which is what
basically dr fate uses or at least one
of his magical artifacts and i never
really thought
about that to be honest i mean obviously
it's an upside down insignia of dr fate
but it was kind of cool because i
just to kind of clear something i do
understand the notion of like the gods
of chaos in the real world like egyptian
gods of chaos and whatnot that much i
did grasp
in terms of whether or not it was being
rolled over into dc comics that's what i
was uncertain about that's what i was
hitting you guys up about um it seemed
like you guys more or less had the same
answer i did that in the real world it
exists but as far as
as you know in the comic book landscape
we're not 100 sure we just kind of
assume that what's hap what what exists
in the real world exists here in this
comic that's basically what's happening
tom taylor's just rolling it over but
the long and short of it is that a guy
by the name of strasser who you know
dirk strasser who we've seen in the
previous video who was
basically a german soldier during world
war ii had managed to get his hands on
the amulet and in doing so
was basically told by the leader of the
german soldiers which obviously we're
not naming for obvious reasons um had
basically tasked him with like
possessing generals and essentially
seeing
what all this thing could do right and
in doing that he actually was turning
his soldiers on each other he was having
soldiers you know basically
friendly firing on one another and
really just creating a whole bunch of
chaos right now the boy commandos were
more or less caught in the crossfire and
in fact it was one of these things where
andrei shavard seemed to be the only one
who was going to make it out but in the
midst of all this
suddenly you had the arrival of the jsa
right and so uh with this being the case
essentially the jsa kind of comes in and
starts you know tending to the various
people who were injured and at the same
time they also start interrogating the
general and that's when the general
basically kind of reveals his hand to a
degree in the sense that he's possessed
by derek strasser using the amulet of
chaos and then in turn
offs himself and so from there what ends
up happening is that with dr fate
picking up on the fact that there's some
kind of magical presence here something
that basically means that the the minds
of these generals are not their own that
somebody's essentially taking them over
that what strasser ends up doing is
realizing he'd been thinking too small
that in realizing that he could
basically possess these various
individuals and then have a whole host
of people fight against each other that
he could expand this out right he could
potentially possess more than one person
or he could move from being a general to
possessing like
superheroes right and that's what ends
up happening that he basically ends up
possessing
johnny thunder and his wizard i'm sorry
in his genie is now something to
understand
is that johnny thunder was arguably the
most powerful member of the
of the justice society of america back
in the day and the reason
is is kind of twofold the first is that
the spectre's powers were not fully
developed we didn't really know the full
length of what it was the spectre could
do we knew he was a representation of
god's vengeance but that envelope hadn't
been pushed right we didn't know
everything that he could do but with
johnny thunder we did right we knew that
his genie was all powerful it could warp
reality
it could do virtually anything it wanted
to right so imagine somebody like like
franklin richards or the marquis of
death if he were a good guy imagine that
before we ever had that and that was
basically what dc comics was
taking over and and controlling johnny
thunder basically led to him sort of
going on a rampage
leading this genie going on a rampage
and tearing up huge sections of of what
looks like germany and berlin right
because we're at the the tail end of
world war ii meaning at this point you
know german forces have kind of been
consolidated right back into germany
again and berlin's like the last great
not really last great battle but like
the last big battle that takes place but
the idea here
is that where the a lot of the german
conflict is being fought you know by
various other allied forces the jsa
is fighting against what's basically the
genies of
johnny thunder like that's basically
what's happening here the genie is going
through and just kind of losing its mind
now the others
other members of the jsa are doing what
they can where they can't trying to
liberate people trying to free people
trying to make sure people don't get
caught in the crossfire the downside to
this
is that when you know with with johnny
thunder himself he actually ends up
perishing
because while the genie is running amuck
the jsa tends to johnny thunder only to
realize that he is basically possessed
and so where you end up having you know
him
this kind of mocking you know the the
various people who were there
you basically end up having a hot girl
who ends up taking out johnny thunder
basically ends up destroying him and it
was the only real way to bring the
conflict to an end it didn't seem like
there was any other means to eliminate
dirk strasser possessing him right so
they end up losing one of their own and
so
in response to that the specter actually
ends up doing something relatively
controversial right because of the fact
that all this was started by germany's
leader at the time you end up having him
taking the amulet and then flying
directly to berlin to where germany's
leader's at and then having him do
himself in
right which historically we know that
happened we just we know it wasn't the
actual
actually the specter who did it right
but with respect to returning and coming
back
jim corgan comes to this realization
that the power confined within this
artifact is
too much for one man to control it it
seems like it's one of these things
where it wants to spread chaos it wants
to spread fear and it'll do it by any
means that it possibly can
like it has a will of its own it's
almost like the ring from lord of the
rings right you know the the ring wants
to return back to
to uh you know was it sauron whatever
that guy's name was the giant eye the
all-seeing eye you know one does not
simply walk into mordor you guys
understand what i'm talking about but
the long and short of this is that jim
corgan realizes this artifact is too
powerful for any one person to have
right if anybody ever were to get their
hands on it again then basically it
would lead to chaos it would lead to the
amulet wanting to spread
as much fear and chaos as it possibly
can and while the person is using it at
the same time
being influenced by it and so he tells
alan scott get rid of this
right get rid of this thing and so what
ends up happening is they you know
there's a kind of conversation between
alan scott and dr midnight right and the
whole time andrei chabard is listening
because as far as they're concerned they
seem to be asleep and what he ends up
saying at least what alan scott ends up
saying is he buried it in a chest
in the deepest part of the ocean at 36
000 feet down he basically buried it in
challenger deep right in the mariana
trench which for those of you guys who
are not aware is
is the single deepest part of the ocean
and the only the only
person that i'm aware of and i could be
wrong here but the only person i'm aware
of that ever actually made it to
challenger deep
was james cameron right when he took a
little personal submersible and a
control dive and went all the way down
to challenger deep right now here's the
important thing to understand
at that point the pressure is insane
right because you've literally got all
that
all that matter being pulled towards the
core of the earth by by the earth's
gravitational pull right if he were to
have exited
the the little submersible uh assuming
that he could even get the door open in
the first place but if he were to exit
that thing it would have
crushed him down to nothing right
instantaneously right the pressure is
just so extreme
it's like being pushed in by walls from
all sides right there's no way he would
have survived for somebody like green
lantern
sure because he's got the protection of
his ring that can keep him safe and can
well withstand the rigors of uh of the
core of
the earth or at least once you get down
to that deeper part of the ocean but
with this revelation
the joker in turn tells harley okay now
we know what we're doing
right we're going down to the deepest
part of the ocean we're going to go down
here we're going to grab this chest
we're going to take this amulet now this
is a terrifying prospect the joker in
possession of an amulet that wants to
spread fear in chaos
sounds horrifying right an amped up
powerful joker in possession of other
people
it's one thing when a joker did what he
did during end game which is where he
basically jokerized
the justice league it's another when
he's in possession of them right that's
a whole different beast and i'm actually
really excited to find out what this
looks like so with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you guys are new here to comments
explain make sure you hit the sub button
to become part of the rob core if you
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like
and i will catch you all later peace
[Music]
we will not tolerate incoherence
[Music]
up
[Music]
you